Jennifer is with us in Charleston hi
Jennifer how are you how you doing Dave
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up well I have read your Total Money
Makeover and I have also gone through
financial peace and as I was going
through financial peace I realized that
I am house poor so right now I put my
house on the market to sell but everyone
around me is telling me that I'm doing
the wrong thing that I should hold on to
my house how much how much is your house
payment
21:40 a month and what is your take home
pay
it is $4,300 is my regular take-home
pain I also have a part-time job that
brings in an extra thousand dollars a
month so about 5,300 okay so without the
part-time job your house payment is
fifty percent of your income yes sir and
people around you think that's smart the
people around you is dumb they said I
should hold on to it for about two more
years they're dumb unless your income is
going up dramatically you have a house
you can absolutely cannot afford I'm not
even sure how you got qualified for this
your house payment is 50% of your
take-home pay yes sir mm-hmm
I mean so I don't know who unless
they're gonna start paying the payment
for you I don't these people giving you
advice probably don't need to be
listened to well where I am is you know
in Charleston it's one of the
fastest-growing cities you know that's
what the prices are here you don't get a
pass on math because the real estate
market is hot all of a sudden it doesn't
matter math is math doesn't matter
because Charleston's hot
so is Nashville so is California so
Dallas
so is every other city listening out
there just about right now real estate
prices are spiking everywhere but you
cannot spend 50% of your take-home pay
on the house and be anything but broke
so I don't know
can I have them how somebody can tell
you that this is a great idea that you
need to hold on to this now is your
income getting ready to double in the
next few years
nope what people are suggesting is that
you know I get a roommate or air B&B and
do other things to try to help me offset
the cost of the house because you can't
afford the house yeah yeah I
you do what you want to kiddo people are
stupid is what people are and people who
suggest you keep a house with a house
payment of 50 percent of your take-home
pay you're stupid
I wouldn't keep it if I were you I'd be
out of in a heartbeat that's ridiculous
that's no life at all you don't do
anything but think about this house 24
hours a day this house owns you you
don't only it